les retraités français se mobilisent ce
jeudi manifestation à paris à l'appel de
neuf organisations syndicales elles
réclament une augmentation des pensions
et des retraites rassemblement suivi par
notre reporter nadège abderrazak
à les retraités demandent une retraite
digne nadège
[Musique]
absolument retraités à martyriser un c
est l'un des slogans scandés aujourd'hui
lors de cette manifestation aujourd'hui
quelques milliers de participants ont
fait le déplacement d'un peu partout en
france pour participer à ce rendez vous
aujourd'hui vous l'avais dit à l'appel
de neuf organisations syndicales dont la
cgt fsu solidaires ou encore force
ouvrière l'objectif hand ce
rassemblement et bien c'est la défense
des pensions de retraite la défense du
pouvoir d'achat de la sécurité sociale
et des libertés individuelles je vous
propose d'écouter certains manifestants
que l'on a pu interroger tout à l'heure
pour évidemment la revoir ya 100 euros
près
on brasse que là par exemple on vient
d'avoir un petit pourcentage mais bon ça
fait pas le taf parce que si vous voulez
vous - grosso modo plus cher après j'ai
beau me 10% quoi donc 10 % c'est quand
même pas rien et puis encore moi je suis
pas un des plus malheureux par rapport à
d'autres voila voila eu en compte les
pièces à la fin du mois oui parce que
j'ai alors je veux donner le montant de
ma retraite
comme j'ai une carrière courte comme la
plupart des com comme beaucoup de femmes
donc je touche 575 euros de retraite par
mois et je vis seule avec ça le but
essentiel de ses attaques contre les
retraités c'est vraiment deux cas c'est
le régime par répartition est montré
notamment aux générations qui arrivent
qu'il vaudrait mieux un système par
capitalisation parce que regarder les
retraités comme et finalement on le
rassure pas un avenir quoi
des retraités qu'ils estiment être les
grands oubliés de la politique d'
emmanuel macron alors il leur réclame
évidemment une augmentation des pensions
de retraite ils réclament également un
minimum retraite au smic et puis le
protestent également contre le projet de
réforme de
des retraites ils estiment qu'ils
veulent en tout cas se faire entendre à
ses retraités lors de cette campagne
présidentielle espère bien et bien avoir
raison à ce sujet de leurs
revendications
merci beaucoup nadège à abderrazak